I swear I am NOT trying to be cute I
just I'm leaving soon and my hair is
almost dry and I just don't feel like
doing it so I put it in braids so that
it might get like a natural crimp to it
so it looked like I wasn't trying and
because I am overly explaining myself it
means I am trying hi welcome to fry
diarrhea I'm gonna take you through some
of the things that happened to me this
week that you didn't know about
necessarily on Saturday night I got to
be part of the comedy festival riot la I
didn't show called roustabout which is
hosted by Kurt Braunohler and if you
don't know who he is you're an idiot
I mean with potential to find out who he
is by googling him was a really amazing
kind of like a late-night variety talk
show extravaganza of weird and absurd
and silly and fun and I got to be
interviewed by Kurt I got a lie detector
test I met some of you there and it was
really fun there were male strippers and
Smurfs
I'm pretty sure the Russian male
stripper was hitting on me backstage hi
Alex he asked me my name and where I
live but that two question conversation
took about 20 minutes because I kept
having to ask him to repeat himself
because I couldn't understand what he
was saying
then this here's the thing
I mean a car look at my weirdo hair this
is what happens when I let my hair dry
naturally it expresses itself
artistically the memory in heaven I
signed 1000 camp Takota posters we're
signing Camp Takota poster my signature
about write checks in my name derp derp
beautiful and the table with the
scissors in the glass
deafening over here I think this is what
happens when you sign posters so if you
haven't purchased the care package that
has a signed poster and it please do
this wrist is so strong whoa oh and then
Hannah and mamrie night did an interview
on showbiz tonight'
for CNN's showbiz tonight' does that
have TV and things work like oh hi what
are we doing today well today we have a
very exciting day we're gonna have our
very first on TV interview together
showbiz tonight' which is relevant to us
and I like showbiz nighttime yeah back
then here's a clip from the interview I
own this I just think it's hilarious
that my first on TV interview I have
painted cupcakes on my breasts you're
welcome yeah me an hour
oh then Tyler Oakley invited Hannah and
mamrie and Connor Franta and I out to
the looking premiere looking as a new
show on HBO and it's great we have to
see two episodes of it and go to the
after-party and we had a great time
you
[Music]
to get covered livestream talking about
health insurance with an alert if you
missed it here are some wild picks we're
leaving the event and you take any
footage their business I put a towel on
my head and a mustache on my face
all in the name of health insurance one
of the Wayans brothers was there when I
was leaving and everyone made a very big
deal about it one day I'll be a Wayans
well there's some stuff that happened to
me this week do you like this kind of
video I don't know I just want running
it I forgot that to tell you guys a
couple things one then I went ranting
Helbig stands her self-serving prick so
I've been wearing this ring and a lot of
videos and some of you have asked about
given to me by a friend Liz and I really
like her and her jewelry so I just
wanted to let you guys know that the
link to her website that she tells me
Julie rottenness down there
speaking of girly things there's a brand
new episode of Graces faces today
so please go click there's a link on my
face click it that was so clean two days
ago so clean whose feet could these be
no my feet would they be he is 30 30
feet what is that oh you're offended